improving data from asia boost the hope
of a recovery of the global economy and
also the eurozone runs better but what
is behind all their news and figures
that's what I'm talking about with
Stefan Schneider of Deutsche Bank
research mr. Schneider how did the divx
perform in August the dbx should have
inched up another 10 4 percentage point
two point six after is somewhat stronger
improvement in July so the global
economy is on a gradual recovery pace
and it's basically fueled by better
numbers coming out of Asia and Europe
looking at Asia especially a China that
we see very quite good figures right now
what is behind that not quite good I
mean it's always against the concerns
that China might move towards a hard
hard landing which was prevailing just a
few weeks ago and now we have seen the
most recent PMI figures which are above
the boom-bust threshold of 50 we have
seen some better credit growth numbers
and investment numbers so it seems that
the economy is gaining traction that
maybe the seven and a half percent in q2
was the trough of the economic cycle may
be slightly lower number in q3 but then
q4 again a pickup and growth but it's
largely the fuel by credit growth and
investment spending it's not fueled by
the external side if you look at the new
export orders in the PMI they are
actually pretty sluggish also the US has
presented figures for gross domestic
product which was very positive like
2.5% could this also boosts the global
economy to a certain extent yes that was
the second estimate the revision a
perturbation from the initial estimate
which was 1.7 to 2.5 but you have to
have in mind these are quarterly
annualized figures so in kind of
European measure you have to divide it
by 4 and then they look somewhat less
impressive if you look at the reasons
for the upper tradition it was mainly
better net exports and given the overall
global environment this
unlikely to continue but the domestic
side especially the income side is still
relatively weak therefore I don't think
that the u.s. is on a very strong growth
dynamics and I don't think that the US
will become their global growth
locomotive over the next course okay so
yes I can't hop Europe in the growing
but we have seen a recovery in the
eurozone the second quarter of this year
so what does that mean for the William
well a recovery is maybe too much of a
word but after six quarters of decline
rate a positive quadrant quarter change
gdp growth of point three it was largely
driven by the two large economies
Germany and France which is surprisingly
strong numbers which are partly one-offs
but still by now if we look at our other
indicators as well it seems like you
know growth modest growth can be
maintained in the second half of the
year which means that although gdp on an
annual average will shrink by another
point for probably but it's not as bad
as the previous year we're trying by
point six okay so we will talk about yet
the euro crisis and new aid packages
later on thank you so far mr. Schneider
signs of recovery in the eurozone but
not everywhere the Greek drama continues
to unfold we will talk about this later
on and you can watch the full interview
on DW de / english / mate in germany